hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es eine torte und zwar habe
ich einen ukas schoko kirsch torte
gebacken und dies wirklich super einfach
und wenn ihr zum beispiel den teig am
vorabend oder am vortag herstellt können
die torte auch super schnell zu ende
bringen ich habe jetzt heute aber auch
alles an einem tag gemacht es geht auch
super einfach so meeres auge dabei und
deswegen würde ich sagen starten wir
gleich mit dem zeit und ich zeit nicht
auf einmal die zutaten für den teig
brauch ich sechs eiweiß eine prise salz
30 gramm zucker 150 gramm butter 150
gramm zucker etwas meinl extrakt sechs
eigelbe 200 gramm schokolade 150 gramm
mehl und zwei teelöffel backpulver ich
nehme die zahl bitterschokolade und die
wird jetzt geschmolzen im wasserbad darf
ich jetzt ein bisschen wasser in monats
teekanne und hab da jetzt einfach eine
kleine schüssel drüber müssen nur
aufpassen dass eben kein wasser in die
schokolade kommt
sobald ein teil geschmolzen ist gebe ich
den rest mit reinen das passt auf jeden
fall mit rein und so lange kann ich
jetzt schon mal hier weitermachen und
zwar führe ich jetzt zuerst eiweiß und
dadurch dass ich jetzt eiweiß und eigelb
nicht zusammen röhre kann sich eben
vorher eiweiß steif schlagen und der
teig wird dadurch noch etwas lockerer
als jetzt kommt eiweiß eine saubere
fettfreie schüssel
das ist ganz wichtig weil ansonsten sich
das nicht steif schlagen lässt da kommt
die preise zahlen schnitt dazu und jetzt
wo ich das einmal steif
wenn der schnee am start ist ein
bisschen zucker mit rein und zwar bewegt
der zucker dass ich mir später nicht
blockt und sich gut mit dem restlichen
zeit verbindet ist einfach es weiterhin
das reicht schon steht in schnell kurz
zur seite und kann jetzt in einer
anderen schüssel schon mal butter und
zucker und vanille extrakt verrühren
a
und dafür nehmen die jetzt nicht einen
schneebesen sondern nimmt einfach so
eine flachere aber falls sie mit einem
handrührgerät arbeitet könnt ihr
natürlich auch da die schneebesen
jetzt ist die eier zucker mischung
schönen weiß cremig jetzt kann auch die
eigene person am besten immer eins nach
dem anderen immer kurz warten bis
berührtes und an das nächste
und sobald sie dann verrückt sind kommt
jetzt noch die schokolade mit rein
die soll jetzt nicht heiß sein aber
diese auch jetzt nicht heißen wasserbad
war
jetzt kann ich mehl und backpulver
vermischen sieht das ganze jetzt hier
mit rein und für die zutaten jetzt nur
mit einem schneebesen 1
gebe ich den eischnee mit reinen zuerst
einmal nur ein bisschen gibt es unter
und dann kommt auch der 53
jetzt will ich den teig in meine
vorbereitete backform und zwar habe ich
einen tortenring auf 26 zentimeter
eingestellt und den tortenring auf dem
backblech mit einer bank folie gesetzt
sind so leicht verstreichen
und jetzt wird der teig im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 160 grad ober unterhitze
für ungefähr 30 minuten gebacken während
der teig es noch packt kann ich schon
mal ein bisschen was von der deko
vorbereiten
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier jeweils 100
gramm sahne und 100 gramm lukas jetzt
kommt die sahne in einen kleinen topf
und wird kurz aufgekocht und dann ruhig
gleich den nougat mit rein
di luca zahn natürlich jetzt noch mal
kurz um und da kann ich sie in den
kühlschrank stellen und abkühlen lassen
bis du wieder kühlschranktemperatur
angenommen hat und sobald der teig
gebacken ist lasse ich ihn auch abkühlen
und danach geht es mit der füllung
weiter jetzt ist das heck abgekühlt ich
hatte ihnen auch noch etwa eine halbe
stunde im kühlschrank soll ist dass ich
gleich besser abschneiden kann ich ihn
vom tortenring lösen
und hier ist übrigens ganz normal dass
das so ein bisschen ausläuft das war
jetzt kein flüssiger teig deswegen habe
ich jetzt wentorfer ring auch nicht mit
backpapier eingeschlagen sondern hat
einfach die back folie genommen aber
wenn ich mal ein richtig flüssigen teig
ab dann schlag ich den tortenring immer
gern mit backpapier 1
und jetzt schneide ich den tortenboden
zweimal waagerecht durch das geht am
besten mit einer torte wege
solche drei torten würden und falls ihr
den teig also wenn ihr zweiter könnt ihr
den zeit gern am vorabend schon packen
dann bröselt er auch nicht so sehr der
brüssel jetzt ein bisschen man einfach
noch sehr frisch ist nämlich den
tankdeckel und nehmen den jetzt als
boden damit ich später als tight wickeln
diese schöne gerade fläche habt und den
muss jetzt aber einmal umdrehen
jetzt kann ich einen tortenring um den
boden setzen und habe hier vorne jetzt
nochmal zwei zutaten und zwar 400 und
etwa 150 gramm hersteller nämlich dass
not und nimmt erstmal nur die hälfte und
gibt es hier in einem kleinen topf und
kann jetzt erstmal die eine hälfte
schmelzen dann vom herd herunter ziehen
und dann kommt die zweite hälfte mit
dazu
jetzt kommt das ganze hier rein dann
haben wir gleich eine richtig schöne
leckeren oberschicht
hilfen mittleren boden draufsetzen
bisschen flach drücken aber wirklich
ganz vorsichtig
jetzt stelle ich das kurz in den
kühlschrank für etwa zehn minuten und
kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal dass
kelly etwas erwärmen
jetzt rächt sich dass kesha lee noch auf
den zweiten tortenboden
und dann kommt jetzt noch der teig
deckel drauf
und jetzt muss ich die torte erst einmal
für etwa eine halbe stunde mindestens
kühlen bis das fest ist und dass kirche
wieder abgekühlt und dann kann ich die
torte dekorieren die tat ist jetzt durch
gekühlt und jetzt kann ich den token
ring lösen
ich habe ich gerade aus dem
reingeschnitten ich hab mich die ma
abgelenkt macht nichts das gebe ich
jetzt wieder dran
jetzt kann ich die komplette torte mit
etwas kirche lebe streichen das ab jetzt
wieder erhitzt und kann das einfach mit
einem pinsel auftragen
den rand streiche jetzt einfach noch mal
so ein bisschen mit einer palette glatt
und da muss sich die torte noch mal für
eine halb stunde kühl und dann kommt
gleichen kurve töricht obendrauf
die torte es jetzt gut durch gekrönt
jetzt wird sie mit kuvertüre überzogen
ich habe jetzt hier bereits 200 gramm
zar peter kuvertüre über dem wasserbad
erwärmt und dies ist auch schon
geschmolzen
also das sieht man jetzt hier auch ganz
gut und damit die kuvertüre jetzt die
perfekte temperatur bekommt gebe ich
jetzt diese 100 gramm hier mit rein das
ist sie da die methode mitarbeiter ein
drittel methode und jetzt hat
dekorateure etwa 50 grad und kühlt jetzt
durch die stückchen auf etwa 29 30 grad
herunter und hat dann später keinen
grauschleier da gebe ich jetzt noch ein
stückchen kokosfett mit rein
das sind etwa 30 gramm und jetzt
versuche ich das ist die kuvertüre
komplett geschmolzen ist und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt hier schon
mal die torte auf ein abkühlen gitter
zählt
und das setzt sich jetzt diesen torten
retter drunter dann bleibt die
arbeitsfläche wenigstens sauber
jetzt ist die kuvertüre temperiert und
ich habe jetzt hier übrigens noch einen
bogen backpapier darunter denn ich denke
es läuft jetzt alles gleich ein bisschen
aus und so habt ihr einfach wirklich
nicht so viel zeit in der küche skills
dir das am besten in die mitte und
verteilt dann mit einem mit einer
palette
o
und jetzt hat sich die torte auf den
anderen backpapier bogen und stellen sie
dann noch mal in den kühlschrank
matthäus natürlich bei seiner tochter
immer so ein parcours türe reste weil
man einfach mehr schmerzen muss als man
braucht aber ich zeige euch jetzt was
ihr wieder im rest tun könnt und zwar
könnt ihr jetzt einfach mit den mandeln
komplex um zum beispiel so hart und
trinke box nehmen und selber shokof oder
nachttisch
die torte ist jetzt gekühlt und jetzt
kann ich hier noch die sahne aufschlagen
da nehme ich jetzt gleich noch zwei
teelöffel sein apartment dazu und kann
die torte gleich dekorieren
er schreibt die sache jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel und hat vorne eine
sternstunde drauf stehen und nehme jetzt
hier einen toten ein teil der jetzt auf
der seite 12 und auf der seite 16 teile
und ich nehme ist die seite mit zwölf
teilen
aber falls ihr kleine stücke haben wollt
nehmt einfach die andere seite oder
markierte sitzt einfach mit einem messer
jetzt kommen hier die tupfer noch drauf
jetzt mache ich noch einen tupfer in die
mitte jeweils und da kommt dann noch
eine kirsche obendrauf
die torte selbst fertig und ich kann sie
jetzt auch gleich anschneiden da bin ich
mal gespannt
ja ich bin jetzt erst gekommen ich weiß
nicht was drin ist ich weiß nicht was
dran ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht
ich weiß nur wenn sie nicht wenn sie gut
schmeckt dann ist sie nicht gesucht und
der papa david gleich probiert oder
sowie laura probieren kopf also die
samira tierfreundin dabei heute ist die
laura nicht dass mir hinter der kamera
und jetzt lasst und laura probiert unter
paragraph aber auch probieren okay ich
zwei gabeln okay jetzt zeige ich ja
schon ziemlich einfach vor die kamera
so sieht es nämlich aus das ist eine
hypothetische kirche aus der türkei das
riecht ja ich weiß das weil die kosten
ins kino 95 30 halt so okay jetzt
probieren wie laura also zuerst die
laura laura hier und ich probiere auch
einmal bei murat ins mikrofon sprechen
ich ehrlich sein papa ist sich böse ganz
gut okay fragt man heute lade erste
schock
also hier also unten haben wir erst wenn
diese drei teigschichten unten noch mit
nougat gefüllten oben mit kirsche legen
gebt mal das stück hoch alles will ich
hab mir noch ein bisschen sahne zu
machen hat marc fascher schwarzwälder
kirschtorte muss ich sagen so ähnlich
sah es als schwarzwälder kirsch
schwarzwälder kirsch los
ok ich finde jetzt für da ist es wie
eine party geeignet ich finde aber es
ist ein kuchen der ist ziemlich mächtig
aber ich möchte ich mag halt viel luft
drin viel schokolade drin also mehr
stückchen geht natürlich ums riechen
schoko lieferbar sein
aber naja orte in kleinere stücke
schneiden dem was zum beispiel in 16
stücke einen teil
falls sie jetzt auch lust bekommen hat
auf dieses zuvor leckere torte geht auch
sellings - klopft der etat steht noch
mal das rezept für euch und ich wünsche
euch auf jeden fall ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken und bis zum nächsten mal so
lauer durchsetzt seine ehrliche meinung
bekommst jetzt fünf euro verlieren so
sieht sie nicht geschwächt
danach machen also foyer